stanno eliminando a vicenda sono io
incolpato promesso che destino la spada
benvenuti side story
oggi giocheremo ad amon gas 3a e 3b
giocheremo a questi nuovi giochi among
us che sono in 3d oppure sono reali o
sono superstrada insomma aveva loro e
alla fine del video dovrete scrivere nei
commenti qual è stato il vostro
preferito e mi volete dare un voto da 1
a 10 a ogni gioco che proveremo diamo un
pò professore questi giochi social
questa super di vernice questa volta non
giocheremo con voi ma giocherò con
persone a casa online che non ci conosce
quindi chissà cosa succederà poi
lasciate un bel mi piace se volete
vedere altri gameplay among us se questo
video raggiunge i 10 mila mi piace fare
un altro gameplay among us consegnatici
poi nei commenti e tipo di gameplay
vorreste vedere se non avete visto lo
scorso gameplay in cui giochiamo i
giochi paurosi andate a vederlo dopo
questo video perché su questo per
divertentissimo mettetevi comodi
prendete il tè caldo
poco prima il gioco si gioca si chiama
molto semplicemente impostore allora
praticamente noi stiamo appunto come i
personaggi di among us è solo che è in
3d è più nella che vedete che dice la
cretina spaziale come arma o una sorta
di spada gigante allora
allora scegliamo il server europa e
giochiamo ok è così ma io il nome anita
stories si può sapere che io la
maglietta celeste mettiamo un po che
cosa c'è allora rimasti sono i vari
colori sobri celeste allora come armi
abbiamo un ammazza un coltelo gigante
una spada
cos'è questa una carta ma anche fra i
cappelli in 3d sembra molto carino ma
vediamo come sarà il gioco come questo
cappello questo questo mio piacere
questo stanno tutti arrivando che strano
vedere in tutta in triestino da babbo
natale rosso la navicella spaziale
bellissimo in 3d
dai su sbrigatevi stiamo nome di dieci
lo so una parrucca voglio quelli bianchi
ovvio il verde a noi casco come è fatta
vedere con altro si provano ma stiamo
assistendo
ci sono tre impostori
oddio 3 in pratica invece di dire crew
me it qua dice innocente cioè non sai
cosa dovremmo fare dove sono perché mi
disse che se sono io non sono un
impostore perché mi dice chi segua anche
gli innocenti posso aiuto quel giallo
era molto molto sospetto di emergency e
apple che succede arancione
ho preso ma nessuno ballate dicono siano
che sarebbe celeste non sono io el'altro
usare un altro titolo blu pare scrivo
perché ma questo si chiama in potter o e
l'impostore anno giunti già votato tutto
a consultarsi va bene ok dicono che ok
chiedere perchè ha ucciso qualcuno
dicono ci fidiamo vediamo come
l'animazione dell'eliminazione
carichissimo posto devo dire che questo
bunga 3d per ora è molto molto carino
anche se mi dispiace che non sto
giocando con voi perché poi siete molto
divertenti molto più bravi molto più
intelligenti molto più furbi quindi
magari la prossima volta potremo giocare
con noi prosegue ho visto che è la
stessa online vi rimarranno perché poi
anche tu hai pulsante chi lo vuol dire
che c'è un impostore acchiatura no io
non sono un impostore ma non so perché
ho anche io il pulsante kg che nel
frattempo non sto facendo nessuna tassa
e poi vedere le mappe private incolpino
sono in giro a controllare allora dove
dovrei andare qui qui vicino 3 3 ma
nuovamente un report chi sarà altri tre
ne sono stati eliminati 3 marrone ha
votato e dire che il giallo safe sono i
ha incolpato
guarda dice blu blu ha detto che non lo
stavo seguendo bufalo green verde fa
dicendo che io sono l'impostore anche
bianco davvero opportuno solo sospettato
di me comunque io voto verde perché
malandri parole hanno creduto che sono
io l'impostore secondi anche bianco e
blu
[Musica]
martiri che forse gli impostori erano
bianco che infatti mi ha incolpato n
quindi perdono aveva capito niente
all'agire ok proviamo un'altra partita e
poi passiamo al prossimo gioco reale 3d
comunque vi devo dire che questa era
molto carino pezzi quasi a giudizio
abbiamo cappello novi hanno rubato i
colori va beh rimaniamo rosa mette un
bel derby
e allora come arma prendo la spada e
come cappello che che questo corso nome
di scolapasta mascherano scolapasta
questo no allora e sento il cappello
toni cotter of risk and posto e questa
volta così l'impostore impostore info
stories esiste ma come i di un posto ora
è piuttosto mi sono imposto reattiva
bianco e all'arancione allora vediamo un
po venite bravissimo a fare l'impostore
cerchiamo di eliminare qualcuno stesse
rivisti e quindi sa che c'è aiuto non ho
capito che cosa stavo cercando ma che
stanno facendo stanno eliminando a
vicenda a trovare qualcuno che da stanno
facendo le tasche di stanno votando sono
queste stanno lottando
e quindi devo trovare qualcuno da solo
da eliminare questo queste sola forza
ho paura che ci sia qualcuno proviamo
noi siamo bianco capiti anche l'editor
non ci credo l'impostore bianco mi ha
eliminato ah no quello è un altro rotta
e hanno già votato anche limba stanno
parlando comunque una mera già scoperto
anita perché hanno tutti già votato chi
non vive di averla sarà bene che
alimentano parlavo capisco niente carne
comunicando con spazi ne stanno dicendo
niente dai sbrigatevi a vincere fosse
fuori non è meno male perché noi siamo
in pastori quindi vabbe io mo di
eliminare qualcuno prima di essere
eliminati e sospettati noi siamo molto
piccola anche se è molto bello vedere
tutto 3d sembra molto piccoli poi non ci
sono neanche i venti bisogna fare
diverso di idea aspetto cliente qualcuno
qua e poi non fare questo tasco hai
vinto bene abbiamo video non sofia
buconi prossimo se lo so questo gioco si
chiama in poster solo chi si è mangiato
e bisogni dove lo doveva mangiare così
si è scoperto subito che hanno spazzato
buoni ma che betty
gli altri piume ok riproviamo allora
penso di aver capito non devo essere
vista dall'altro e devono mangiarli
tutti e due come quindi devo prima devo
mangiare questa questo si sta
preoccupando prossimo livello non posso
mangiare quello verde perché se non mi
vede quello giallo quello gialloblù è
anche quello giallo e rosso
se mangio quello blu giallo for 10 di
andare attraverso la porta qui che non
mi vede
mi ha riportata allora forza dover
lanciare dal blu
ok vediamo se dicevo prima mangiare il
blu ma secondo me perché non si vede
perché qui ci sono i muri
ok stanno qua se poi in mezzo a lui mi
vede mi chiamo che non si vede che ho
visto alberto ricordiamo di protoni
terme famiglia prova a chiudere la porta
a bra
ok adesso prova ad eliminare blu
no perché mi vede verde no secondo me
perché è prova la vita ne vediamo desire
s
io chiuderei la porta occhio poi andrei
subito qui guerra che ti viene il verde
mangerei prima lui e poi il verde poi
fatto non risolta e maggior chiare
liberarci un livello allora video un pò
[Musica]
guardà se l'immagine di un martello là
dietro forse per distrarli maggio ok ok
attento attento dietro tra l'altro dato
vai modulo subito facile il prossimo
livello quali d'essere sempre più
difficili le cose così come stanno
facendo delle tasche stanno aggiustando
i cavi elettrici penso li aiuto loro si
allontanano in che vai
[Applauso]
e allora in questo nuovo livello abbiamo
una cosa nuova e cioè le armi gestito
web
vediamo questi non devo più per forza
mangiare con i denti il cartello quindi
potrei mangiare giallo poi entrare nel
vento così non mi vediamo by 21 tasto
così non entrerò a si stanno entrando
marga verdi ha scoperto giallo premesso
chiudi la porta così blu non ti vede e
poi prendere e poi prendere verde poi ti
rispondi di nuovo nasconditi brava no
non mi ma nasconde orario ma che è
sbagliato corri in rosa facendo il bagno
ok vai con giallo e blu ha subito otto
anch'io otto barche voglia di dare
scrivetelo nei commenti o gioco su
questo gioco si chiama imposto quindi la
guerra degli impostori non so se saremo
tutti impostori non lo so vediamo
smart muti a raccogliere ma quindi
praticamente lo scopo di ogni livello
qua e prendere tutte le monete d'oro
vede però lei fu prima fa cadere la lava
e la nave va via mi togli vederle nella
moneta devono vedere bravo
il nostro cliente e questo più di
cinismo store è lì che mi aspetta
presunta rottura camminano sulla spada
allora sì esatto che deve essere salvata
per gli forse è meglio togliere prima
questa così tu puoi andare ad ora di
rivincere che possono importare e adesso
puoi salvare rosa ma sempre con lettura
cabine ultimo livello attenzione se un
impostore con una pistola aiuto doveva
salvare posti possono accadere la lavo
addosso poi l'acqua dai proviamo per
richiedere la nuova doc
[Musica]
fox dovevo usare l'acqua per fare le
pietre pensiamo che punta che ha
divertito super divertente abbiamo un 8
anche questo io no io sono tanto qualche
modo ordinato e scrivete di commenti ma
siamo altresì resto non è proprio un
gioco in cui dobbiamo sconfiggere un
poster hermes ma queste among us maker
praticamente in quasi può creare tutto
quello che vogliamo quindi per fare tipo
di viaggi degli avatar delle cartoline
quindi puoi mettere lo sfondo che puoi
il personaggio che vuoi il cappello più
bruciante che c'è questo personaggio
come pet con i capelli
insomma maiale vegas
perché non ha il corno vicari massimo
questo inoltre di quelli in cui che si
può creare quello che si vuole
praticamente con questo si può creare la
propria schermata quindi ad esempio qua
al centro poi potete aggiungere il test
lissimo visto il testo però massimi
piace non è sì mi piace al video 6
come mi raccomando mi piace al video
possiamo anche cambiare il colore della
mobilità mettiamo la viola vediamo
praticamente lo crea come background del
sensore è il movimento bene ragazzi
nostra l'ultimo che possediamo questi
due make allora questo mi piace un sacco
perché puoi fare queste cose io gli do 9
invece quello di prima che puoi cambiare
sarà da sfondo i colori gli do un sette
e mezzo ed allora io gli do un sei a
quello di prima mentre a questo gli do
un bell'otto perché mi piace
l'animazione ma lei che voto date a
questi editeur volte ha preferito il mio
preferito è stato il primo era tutto 3d
è anche quello che dovevano mangiare
degli altri cicli waits scoperti per me
quello che dovevamo mangiare gli altri
tre match ma anche quello leader delle
spalline che bisognava togliere delle
linee at e bisogna la polizia crede voi
il vostro preferito
e come vedete ora cosa c'è scritto io so
sostenibili care musumarra queste
quattro caselline altrimenti sarete
molto sa molto stato quindi cliccate su
una di queste quattro caselline buona
visione
ciao